new polling shows how successful
disintegration as'hab become an American
thinking a prosecutor brings charges
against a Missouri couple defending
themselves from rioters and his
coronavirus starting to flatten i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your online activity should
not be public protect yourself at
expressvpn dot-com /ban a little bit
later on in program we're gonna get to
all of the coronavirus related issues
that are cropping up around the country
what is the proper strategy why is it
that people keep claiming they have the
strategy to stop this thing and then
they actually don't present a strategy
to stop the thing we'll get to all of
that it's actually possible that we've
actually seen the peak already in some
places like Arizona and Texas which
would be great news so we'll get to all
of that but first gotta remind you today
is the day finally the long-awaited book
that I've been talking about for months
at this point how to destroy America in
three easy steps it's now available you
can go over to amazon.com or anywhere
else books are sold and pick it up right
now I could not think of a time when it
would be more relevant it is
extraordinarily relevant the reason it
is so relevant should be obvious from a
brand new poll it is out today from The
Wall Street Journal it is a devastating
poll for the country a devastating poll
for the country because what it really
says is that Americans don't believe
that we share much anymore the only
thing that we share apparently is a
desire to virtue signal the pollsters
but when it comes to what we actually
share as a country the answer is not
much so the premise of my book is I've
talked about before that there are
essentially two visions of American
society one vision of American society
is the unionist vision this is a vision
that suggests that in order for a nation
to survive you have to have a common
philosophy culture and history the
common American philosophy is expressed
beautifully in the Declaration of
Independence that we are endowed by
nature and nature's God with certain
inalienable rights that government is
instituted to protect those rights and
that violation of those rights makes the
government lose its reason for being
that we are all intact with reason we
are all equal before the law these are
the ideas of the Declaration of
Independence and we cherish them and we
hold them dear that our natural rights
are what we call negative rights rights
against other people they're not
positive rights meaning entitlements
from other people entitlements from
government right these were the
principles of the Declaration of
Independence and those principles are
good those principles have brought about
the
of American freedom it brought about the
insane levels of prosperity that not
only Americans enjoy but the rest of the
world enjoys as well those principles
have brought about the end of Nazism and
communism those principles those
principles were instrumental were the
key principles in overthrowing the
dominance of racism and white supremacy
and American life that is the common
American philosophy then there's the
common American culture American culture
was built on a series of beliefs about
the way the world works in a series of
attitudes toward the world and those
attitudes include things like a feeling
of entrepreneurship and adventure the
spirit of Americanism was the spirit of
adventure when you read the Tocqueville
he's constantly talking about where
America can be found what he says is
America can essentially be found on the
frontier that when you look at the the
nature of Americans they are constantly
striving they're constantly building
they are constantly moving and they're
constantly seeking the spirit of
adventure and entrepreneurship is what
characterizes Americans as opposed to de
Tocqueville is picture of Europeans
which was much more sedentary Americans
were constantly on the move constantly
on the go embracing the journey
embracing the adventure not asking for
anything but being granted the freedom
to do with their lives what they would
do it was a spirit of adventure also
there was a culture of tolerance for
other people's rights in understanding
that rights mean that other people may
not use that rights in ways that you
like so the rights of free speech isn't
just your right to speak as you see fit
it relies on a cultural underpinning
that you understand that other people
may not agree with you and they have a
right to free speech to freedom of
association means not only that you have
a right to associate freely but that
others may choose not to associate with
you based on their right to associate
freely you have to have tolerance for
other people's rights that is a culture
of Rights also the culture of the United
States was built on the value of social
institutions that rights were going to
be balanced by duties that every right
came with a consonant duty that a free
country relied as John Adams suggested
on a moral and religious people and that
you required social institutions to
undergird that you required things like
churches you required things like
schools you required social and communal
institutions that were designed to
inculcate virtues so that when people
did exercise their rights that were not
harming one another and finally the
culture of the United States relied on a
a militant defense of those rights a
belief that if others were to be
threatened those rights that you would
stand up for yourself is where the
rights you keeping bear arms comes from
this militant belief
your rights are worthy of defense so
that was the American philosophy in the
American culture and then there was a
picture of American history and that
picture of American history was that
America struggles to live up to its
founding ideals and is gradually moving
toward the fulfillment of those founding
ideals that the story of America is a
nation founded not in 1619 because
slavery was a human Universal is an evil
human Universal and to mention that does
not alleviate in any way America's
responsibility for the sin of American
slavery it is to put that sin into the
context of all human sin hey which is
where all sin belongs right all sin
belongs in the context of all human sin
because to myopically focus on the sin
of america at the expense of all of
human history and all over the world is
to miss the point which is that human
beings are innately sinful and do
terrible things to one another and that
the goal of freedom and virtue is to
move human beings beyond that and that's
the story of America is the fight
against human nature by instituting
checks and balances by fighting for
liberty the the cashing of the story of
America on a racial level is the cashing
of the promissory note that was written
in 1776 not the story of the
continuation of 1619 any attempt to link
American life in 2022 1619 is gonna be
very difficult on a practical level it
is much easier to link American life in
2020 to 1776 because frankly America was
not found in 1619 it was founded in 1776
and the story of America is the gradual
fulfillment of those promises
that's the unionist vision the things
that unify us our philosophy there are
our culture and there are history right
those are things that you have to unify
any can any nation that hopes to be
cohesive in any sense or fashion and
then there's the disintegration is
vision the disintegration is vision
wants to tear down the entire system and
so they castigate the system as racist
sexist bigoted homophobic they don't
castigate particular Americans is that
because those Americans that's perfectly
obvious there are Americans or racists
and sexist and bigots and homophobes
they do exist but the system itself the
system that was created by the
Declaration of Independence and then
preserved by the Constitution of the
United States with its amendments over
time that system is not racist that
system is not sexist that system is not
homophobic that system is not brutal and
vicious that system is a system of
freedom but disintegration to suggest
that that system is indeed an attempt to
re-establish and we inculcate
hierarchies of power so disintegration
to say about American philosophy that is
just
wrong there are no rights the pre-exists
government government is the source of
your rights government is the source of
your privileges and government is the
source of your entitlements rights
themselves are not rights you have
against other people rights instead are
things that you get from the government
to have a right to Social Security of
Rights a housing of right to health care
now the founders would have thought this
was bizarre because obviously all of
those quote unquote rights require
something from other people as opposed
to the right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness or the right to
life liberty and property that doesn't
require anything of anybody if I have a
right to life that just means you're not
allowed to kill me if I were right to
housing it that means you know have an
obligation to build me a house that is a
very different thing and philosophers
have termed this difference negative
rights versus positive rights so
disintegration is say there are positive
rights which means essentially I can use
the government to point a gun at you and
steal your stuff right that's the nature
of positive rights the the
disintegration as'
all men are not equal before the law
there's no such thing as equal rights
before the law because equal rights are
a lie because if we were to just apply
the law evenly between individuals well
that might end with group injustice
right because what if one group commits
more crimes than another group well then
that means the group is being treated
unjustly this is why you see the the
disintegration is left very often citing
criminal justice disparity statistics in
order to suggest that America's system
is innately broken without reference to
the nature of the crimes that are being
committed by individuals as the people
on the right will say you have to name
the people who are innocent who are in
jail who shouldn't be in jail and I'm
fine with it people are left will say it
doesn't matter if they're innocent they
they're they could be guilty and in jail
the system created the disparity
therefore the system is guilty of the
disparity so the only rectification for
that is that the law does not treat
people equally the law treats people
differently based on race or victim
status of the group to which they belong
in the United States at the the
disintegration aset that the American
philosophy of limited government is
wrong the only path toward utopia is a
non limited government no checks and
balances no federalism top-down cram
downs that will change human nature
because the philosophy of the United
States the Unionists philosophy of the
United States relies on a simple idea
human beings are not angels they are not
Devils there are human beings they're
capable of sin they're capable of great
good this is why you need checks and
balances this is expressed best in James
Madison's Federalist number 51
but disintegration is don't believe that
they believe the human beings this is
what John Dewey said Woodrow Wilson many
of the
20th century progressives they said that
human beings are innately malleable and
the reason that human beings are flawed
is because they live in a capitalist
system shaped by things like the
Declaration of Independence get rid of
that system put in a more just and
equitable economic system and human
beings will change they will change
they'll become better this is the
promise of Karl Marx it was expressed by
progressives in the early 20th century
and that has never waned this belief
that all disparities in the system can
be cured if you just get rid of the
system so American philosophy must be
dissolved American culture has to be
fought according to the disintegration
us a spirit of entrepreneurship is
actually a spirit of exploitation
entrepreneurs adventurers those who
wander forth and sally forth into the
wilds of life and try to conquer and
build those people are exploiters the
best people are the people who rely on
the government to give them things the
best people are the people who demand
things from others because they create
social justice your demand is your
heroism the fact that you want a thing
is what grants you heroism because you
are trying to establish a more equitable
Society if you go and you build for
yourself that means that your reliance
on somebody else to build for you which
means you're an exploiter if however you
demand something from somebody else
you are just demanding that the system
be more just and you are a hero
according to the disintegration us the
spirit of tolerance for others rights is
bad according to disintegration as'
because according to disintegration is
if you tolerate other people's rights
well what if they're bad right what if
what about the the jerk who's not gonna
let a black person go to his business we
have to quash his rights right because
nobody should have a right to do
something that's wrong but listen I can
think that guy's just as much of a jerk
as a desintegration estas
but rights exist and can be used by bad
people in the wrong ways which is why
you need social institutions that
inculcate virtue but disintegration is
fight those social institutions because
they believe that social institutions
are a barrier against government
dominance so church is dangerous because
a church might teach something that
disintegration is don't like the family
structure is an enemy that's why black
lives matter the organization suggests
family structure must be torn down
because the family is the smallest
minority other than the individual
families might teach stuff that the
majority doesn't like families might
teach stuff the government doesn't want
and so family has to be broken down and
finally a culture that understands not
only tolerance for other people's rights
but also fights in on behalf of those
rights that's something that this
integrationists don't like either
because if you fight on behalf of those
rights and you're standing up to a
dominant government and the only thing
that can establish equity in our time is
a dominant government and then finally
American history disintegration to say
about American history that American
history is 1619 American history is the
story of Columbus brutalizing the era
walks it is not the story of Western
civilization's growth in the Western
Hemisphere and how that is bettered the
world the story of Western society is a
story of exploitation
it's the Howard Zinn story about how
everything was Rousseau and beautiful
natural savage wilderness out in the
Western Hemisphere until the evil West
got here with their exploitative ways
human sin did not exist until the West
arrived on these shores that the Western
civilization is a cruel exploitative
place unlike any other civilization
right uniquely exploitative uniquely
evil that narrative has taken a foothold
so that is the battle and the problem is
if the disintegration is win what
exactly holds us together we don't share
a philosophy right basically the
philosophy of disintegration ist's
suggests and whoever holds the majority
should be able to Club the minority over
the head
the only reason by the way the
disintegration is believe this these
days is because they believe they're in
the ascendancy and then the thing about
disintegration is when it comes to
governmental structures is they have no
consistent take on governmental
structures whatever is convenient is
what they will push so sometimes that
means that they are in favor of States
standing up to the federal government so
they're fair in favor of sanctuary
cities because they don't want the
federal government cramming down its
view of immigration on the state and
sometimes it means they want the federal
government to completely run roughshod
over states like the same sex marriage
this integrationist have no consistent
philosophy of government the philosophy
of unionism says that government is
supposed to be both Federalist meaning
that power devolves to the lowest level
and also they're supposed to be checks
and balances at every level to prevent
too much accretion of power and to
prevent people's rights from being
overridden there's no consistent
philosophy of government from the
disintegration as' the philosophy of
government is just whatever gets the job
done whatever moves us closer to utopia
and that means ultimate government power
the goal is ultimate government power so
this all has very significant
ramifications for the for the United
States in the future of the United
States because disintegration asar
basically claiming that their vision of
America in which we share very little we
don't share a history history is just a
series of clubbing is over to the head
they we don't share a culture because we
don't believe that you should have
rights if you think the wrong things
there's more canceled culture
comes in and if you think the wrong
things we should go after your
livelihood we should left your family
we should expose the places where you
live we should Doc's you we should make
sure that if we can we'll use the power
of government against you
this integrationists believe that checks
and balances should go away and that you
don't have any individual rights that
all rights spring from the government
and you can be treated differentially
based on whether you are a part of a
historically marginalized group where he
chosen historically marginalized group
or not right that that's the
disintegration of philosophy and it will
end it'll end with tyranny because that
is the only way this can end when you
get rid of all the checks and balances
what you end up is with tyranny of the
maturity of the mob which is essentially
what many people have called for getting
rid of the United States Senate getting
rid of the Electoral College packing the
courts getting rid of the federalist
system tyranny of the tyranny of the
majority tyranny of the mob which is
something the founding fathers worried
deeply about or alternatively just
tyranny of your Barack or see a tyranny
of a cultural bureaucracy of cultural
elites who know better than you which
means we can't live together because
here's the thing if you want California
and Texas to live together they got to
leave each other alone that is the only
way this works if you want me to share a
country with Bernie then we got it we
got to understand that there are certain
parts of our lives that are inviolable
we have certain rights that are
inalienable if you don't believe that we
can't live in the same country because
then it's just a question of who's got
the government gun which is exactly what
disintegration is one so how does this
matter so I'm in a second I'm gonna get
to a poll showing the disintegration
estar winning that their view of America
as racist as bigoted as cruel their view
of America systems as innately bigoted
it's taken a extraordinary foothold in
American public life and if this
continues there will not be an America
left to stand up for it just will not
exist it'll be a different thing we're
gonna get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that all
this may make you want to rip your own
hair out and then you would be bald
which would be bad you don't want to be
bald instead you want to retain the hair
that you have you got male pattern
baldness that runs your family I do then
you should be taking a look at keeps two
out of three Jews will experience some
form of male pattern baldness by the
time they're 35 the best way to prevent
hair loss is to do something about it
while you still have the hair it's
harder to regrow it than to keep the
stuff you got used to have to go to the
doctor's office for your hair loss
prescription now thanks to keeps you can
visit a doctor online and get hair loss
medication delivered right to your home
they make it easy and delivery
in every three months so you can say
goodbye to pharmacy checkout lines and
awkward doctor visits prevention is key
keeps treatments can take up to four to
six months or more to see results so
it's important to act fast the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair you
will save find out why keeps has more
five-star reviews and any of its
competitors in early one hundred
thousand men trust keeps for their hair
loss prevention medication keeps
treatments started just ten bucks a
month plus for a limited time and get
your first month for free I've been
using keeps myself to keep this lush
head of hair upon this noggin go check
them out right now if you're ready to
take action prevent hair loss co2 keeps
calm slash men to receive your first
month of treatment for free that is ke
EPS calm at slash Bennett go check them
out right now okay so this brings us to
a Wall Street Journal poll that is out
this morning now do I believe that every
aspect of this poll is reflective of
permanent changes in American thinking I
do not I think that very often
polling follows extraordinary amounts of
media coverage so in the aftermath of
the George Floyd protests when posters
were calling up Americans in saying what
do you think of these protests you like
them or do you not like them mmm-hmm I
think a lot of Americans were like I
like them I do I like them and and let's
be real the original protests there were
there wasn't a lot to dislike per se
nobody's in favor of police brutality I
said this at the time I didn't oppose
protests against police brutality what I
opposed was the attempts to conflate
questions of police brutality with the
idea that there's endemic American
racism that can only be removed by a
top-down government or a bottom-up
movement I don't think that's the case I
don't think police officers are
endemically racist I don't think the
American system is endemically racist I
don't think the vast majority of
Americans are racist or tolerate racism
and most of all I do not think that in
order to be quote-unquote anti-racist I
have to stand for tearing down the
system which is the case being made by
Robin D'Angelo and Abram candy which is
an ugly wrong neo-marxist stupid case it
doesn't make sense and not only does it
not make sense it it is innately racist
in and of itself because it exudes that
we have to treat each other as members
of groups rather than individuals I mean
Robin DeAngelo herself says that it is
it is racist to treat people as
individual she says this in white
fragility it's not okay it's just
absolutely crazy okay but unfortunately
because of the way the media have
treated this entire situation and
because the media have attempted frankly
to polarize the conversation around
President Trump and attempted to make
Trump the font head of America the goal
here is
to make Americans feel bad about America
and then say if you want to feel better
about America all you gotta do is get
rid of Trump put your Biden in there and
you'll feel better about America and I
will say that Joe Biden is playing a
smart hand here because what Joe Biden
is doing is he's basically playing dead
in the basement and he's avoiding the
big mistakes when he's asked about
statues for example he'll say yeah we
should probably move the Confederate
statues but we should leave up Columbus
in Washington and Jefferson his radical
left flank is screaming at him no no you
gotta get rid of all of those things and
frankly I don't think that Joe Biden
would be a bulwark against his radical
left flank once in office he himself his
head he would be a transitional figure
but he's playing it smart so the
implicit promise of the media is we are
going to militate against American unity
from now until the election if you elect
Joe Biden then we'll shut up for like
five seconds then of course it'll
restart again remember the Ferguson
riots happened under Barack Obama but
what this polling data shows that
Americans are more and more warm so a
lot of the disintegration astreus
because once you have a majority of
Americans who don't believe in
fundamental American notions of rights
don't believe in that philosophy don't
believe in that culture don't believe in
that history what exactly is supposed to
hold us together other than rage at the
system and what happens after the rage
of the system is vented because it turns
out now they're pretty wildly differing
points of view on what should happen
once you tear down the house once you
turn on the house and it's just a
question of who's in charge a
revolutionaries very rarely have an idea
as to what to do after the revolution is
over right the French revolutionaries
were pretty sure what they wanted to
tear down some of what they wanted to
tear down was good some what they wanted
to tear down was bad it took an awful
lot of blood they tore it down and in
this place they established a tyrannical
Directorate which was eventually
replaced by an actual dictator which was
a vent which was eventually replaced by
a restoration of the monarchy so that
worked out poorly the Russian Revolution
was pretty much sure what it wanted to
tear down right there were whites and
reds and they both wanted to tear down
that Tsarist system and then what
replaced it a significantly worse
communist tyranny that lasted for nearly
all of the 20th century and resulted in
the slaughter of literally tens of
millions of people maybe up to 100
million people in the USSR along depends
on your calculation and so
revolutionaries very rarely know what
they want to do after the Revolution
this is what makes the American
Revolution different is that after the
American Revolution because it was based
on English common law and notions of
philosophy and an Enlightenment ideas
from john locke and such there was a
Friedel attempts to build something in
the aftermath of breaking away from
Great Britain the Revolution was really
a separation I mean the declaration
talks about this it was less of
revolution than a separation impelled by
a gap in thinking I don't think that's
what's going to happen in the United
States if if our unity dissolves in the
face of disintegration ISM it's not like
people know what's coming after it's
just perpetual revolution from here on
in because that's essentially what what
progressives have wanted forever is this
perpetual revolution which is why you
see the woke eating their own right you
see the woke going after the more woke
or the less woke okay so what is this
poll actually show the numbers are
pretty devastating according to The Wall
Street Journal voters and growing
numbers believe that black and Hispanic
Americans are discriminated against a
majority of 56 percent holds the view
that American society is racist a new
Wall Street Journal NBC News poll finds
so that is an incredibly vague question
is American society racist what do you
mean by that Jimmy are there racists in
American society of course you'd be a
fool not to say they're a racist in
American society of course what
percentage of American society is racist
an extraordinary low percentage by every
available metric by actual data very
very low percentage there been studies
that have been done on where America
stands in the world in terms of racial
treatment but I find this America's one
of the least racist countries on earth
it's like America Canada in the UK like
those are the least racist countries on
earth hey by polling did is reported by
The Washington Post back in 2013 America
is not a racist society it is not and I
know it's become cliche to say this but
racist societies do not elect a black
president twice an overwhelming fashion
that is now a racist societies do you
know how I know that because America was
a deeply racist society
can you imagine America electing a black
president in 1960 of course you cannot
of course he cannot not only electing a
black president electing him with an
extraordinary margin over a over a
historic war hero the first time and
over a popular Republican Massachusetts
governor of the second time and then
this is is an extraordinary country
it's an extraordinary country and it's
an extraordinary Society and I don't
know how many Americans can really look
at their neighbors and say my neighbors
are racist the society is racist so if
you believe if a majority of Americans
believe the society is racist how much
of that is really believing the society
is racist and how much of that is just
wishing to dissociate from the society
so you can claim moral superiority
in the in the modeling of Shelby Steele
I think a lot is the ladder but doesn't
really matter because that number is
devastating if a majority of Americans
believe American society's races the
question becomes okay what's the
corrective because when people like me
say okay show me the racist incident or
the person who's doing a racist thing
and I'll fight it with you then people
say well no you can't ask me for
specifics because the society is racist
the very vagary of the statement tears
it the system which of course is the
goal and as we'll see when polled about
whether the American system is
endemically racist large numbers of
Americans then guess which is disastrous
I'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the window
coverings at your home so you've been
upgrading your home it's looking a
little bit better let's be real about
this but I'll tell you you're looking
around still looks dingy why have you
looked at your window coverings
mmm-mmm-mmm I still got those blinds
from the wire circa 2002 you probably do
don't you this is why you need excellent
window coverings and you can do this
quickly and easily and get the best
window coverings available for the best
price at blinds.com blinds.com makes it
simple to shop top-quality blinds shades
and interior shutters from home with
easy online ordering and free shipping
the experts at blinds comm understand
that window treatments are one of those
household items you don't just think
about they can make a huge impact on the
look and feel of your home but you don't
need to do a full renovation I simply
change from what is on your windows you
can change the way light comes into your
home and create a totally different feel
Gotha blinds comm just take a look at
all the options like faux wood blinds
cellular and roller shades even outdoor
shades if you're nervous about trying
them there's really no reason to be
blinds comments helped millions of
homeowners through the process plus they
guarantee the perfect fit whether you do
it yourself you have the measure and
install everything for you upgrading a
blinds easy way to make your house
better we've been doing it ourselves go
right now see how much you can say that
blinds.com
rules and restrictions may apply go
check out blinds.com right now I promise
you you're gonna be upgrading your home
and not gonna be spending a ton on it
blinds.com go check them out right now
okay so the poll finds and Americans of
all races and age groups share
significant concerns about
discrimination nearly two months after
George Floyd a black man was killed in
police custody in Minneapolis is the
Wall Street Journal reporting nearly
three quarters of Americans 71 percent
believe that race relations are either
very or fairly bad a 16 point increase
in February that's not a great shot
considering we've had actual race riots
across the United States egged on by the
white walk left and when you see entire
major American cities shut down for a
while people riot in the streets you
might think oh yeah race relations are
getting worse by the way one of the
things that is important to know race
relations in every poll have been
getting consistently worse since Barack
Obama was elected why well because there
was an optimism when Obama was elected
that we were going to move into the
post-racial era that MLK had once
dreamed of when people would judge each
other on the basis of their
individuality rather than the color of
their skin then we were told that we
can't do that that if you say that I
judge was an individual and not based on
the color of your skin that is in and of
itself racist because you are failing to
recognize the most important factor
about someone which is their race race
relations have been getting steadily
worse it didn't start with Trump the
media who said that it's about Trump
wrong go back and look at the polling
the question of positivity or negativity
about race relations it's been getting
worse every year since Barack Obama was
elected the height of optimism was
literally the week Obama was elected and
then it's been going down ever since in
other signs of substantial shifts in
views on race more voters see racial
bias as a feature of American society
and support protests aimed at addressing
it nearly 60 percent in the survey said
that black people face discrimination
just over half said so of Hispanics
about double the shares from 2008 now
the thing about poll questions is you
have to kind of determine what exactly
are people perceiving when the question
is asked example so if the question was
do black people face discrimination the
answer is obviously yes because there
are racists in American society so sure
I mean of course if the question is does
America's does American society
discriminate against black people
broadly speaking the answer's no if the
question is to America's legal
institutions discriminate against black
people the answer is pretty obviously no
in favor of the in fact the only legal
programs based on race are created to
benefit people who are black right
questions like affirmative action
support has also grown for two of the
public responses to concerns about
inequality the black lives matter
movement and professional athletes
practice of kneeling during the national
anthem so in terms of views on racism
percentage to agree that American
society is racist according to this poll
46 percent of men agree 66 percent of
women agree and these are the women who
have been coddled into thinking so by
The Washington Post and they can write
puff pieces about how you're confronting
your own racism 51 percent of white
Americans say that American society is
racist which by the way is pretty
incredible right half of white Americans
say Americans
ideas racist so who are the other like
so who are the racists the people who
don't say that American society is
racist 78% of black Americans say
American society is races 60% of
Hispanics say American society is racist
now here is the really interesting stat
hey right
82% of Democrats 82% say American
society is racist
45% of independents say it's racist
30% of Republicans say it's racist so in
other words the disproportion here is
not between Democrats and Republicans is
between Democrats and everybody else
Democrats are up at 82 percent say
American Society is racist independents
and Republicans below 50 if you are aged
18 to 34 65 percent believe American
Society is racist if you're above the
age of 65 only 53% believe that American
society is racist so in other words we
have inculcated in young people the
least discriminated against people in
the history of the world in America if
you're 18 years old in America you don't
remember Jim Crow your parents may not
remember Jim Crow if you're 18 years old
that means that you were born after the
year 2000 the idea that you have
experienced vast discrimination in
America between the years 2000 and 2020
is generally absurd that doesn't mean
you haven't experienced racism hey I'm a
Jew I've experienced anti-semitism in
fact I've experienced a fair bit of it
in the last few years you know what that
doesn't mean that American societies
endemically anti-semitic it isn't
Americans noting that there are
anti-semites does not mean that American
society is anti-semitic because it is
not noting that black people experience
racism in their lives is not the same as
noting that American society is
generally racist not the same thing the
conflation of those two things is
incredibly dangerous because what do you
mean when you say American society is
racist you mean it's structures and it's
institutions namely you mean its
philosophy and its culture and its
history
right all the things that tie the nation
together if you call those racist you're
disintegrating them in a steepest look
at race in America in two decades the
Journal NBC News poll shows members of
the two parties hold sharply different
opinions about the extent of racial
discrimination an overwhelming majority
of Democrats 90 percent say black people
are discriminated against whereas 26% of
Americans agreed again these questions
are vaguely worded and they allow a lot
of wiggle room if you say does American
do Americans legal system discriminate
against black Americans that'd be a much
more specific question
82% of Democrats believe American
society is racist only 30% of
Republicans do 57% of voters said they
support the protest sparked by Floyd's
going 58 percent said they are more
concerned with racial inequality as a
result of the demonstrations because
everybody understands that you are sort
of supposed to say this if you weren't I
don't understand why you want concern
with racial problems before this but
apparently people got more concerned in
just in just a few short period a few
short weeks on specific questions like
kneeling in Jolla in in August of 2018
54% of Americans thought that kneeling
during the national anthem to protest
racial inequality was inappropriate only
43 percent of Americans thought it was
appropriate by the way the numbers were
even more on behalf of not appropriate
before Trump was elected Trump jumped
into that culture war a lot of people
took the other side just cuz they don't
like Trump so it used to be like a 60/40
proposition maybe a 65 35 percent
proposition people didn't like kneeling
for the national anthem because they
felt like okay police brutality does not
represent the flag and the flag doesn't
represent police brutality that's absurd
the flag represents the fact that people
get to play athletics for millions of
dollars regardless of race right that's
more representative of the American flag
than incidents of police brutality so
most Americans thought this is a bad
idea
now 52% of Americans say it is
appropriate for athletes and football
players to kneel during the national
anthem 45 percent say it is not
appropriate
again if you believe that the American
flag represents police brutality you're
doing it wrong you're doing it wrong
there are only two groups of people who
actually believe the American flag in
its essence represents police brutality
or defense police brutality white
supremacist and the woke everybody else
recognizes that police brutality is
acting outside the scope of agency and
scope of agency is legal concept if I
deploy you to go get me a pizza as my
agents and then you veer off the road
and decide to strike a child with your
car you have acted outside the scope of
agency and when a policeman acts
brutally that is outside the scope of
agency
nobody said to the policeman go act
brutally the the new in question has
shifted pretty dramatically furthermore
a majority of black voters in the survey
65 percent this is the key question said
that people of color experience racial
discrimination because it is built into
American society including US policies
and institutions right that's the
devastating question so too
in three black Americans believe that
racial discrimination is not endemic to
human nature and it's not just a matter
of individual sin it is built into the
systems which inherently means you got
to tear down the entire system in order
to fight racial discrimination that's a
disintegration astoria and that is being
promulgated by our media it's being
promulgated by folks who are attempting
to foster racial conflict it is a
perspective on American society that is
generally oriented at destroying
anything that could possibly bind us a
plurality of white voters 48% attribute
racial discrimination to individuals who
hold racist views as opposed to
institutions and society as a whole
which by the way is much more accurate
because if you're gonna point to it I've
been saying this for years if you're
gonna say institutional racism you have
to point to the institution and you have
to explain how it is racist and it is
not enough to say well you know policing
when it first started was about slave
catching fast forward 200 years and it's
exactly the same none of this has
Florida crap and because fast forwarding
means you skipped the entire plot okay
just like if you're watching a movie and
you don't know the plot if you started
the first five minutes you fast forward
to the end you don't get the plot if you
go 60 19 20 20 no difference you just
skipped 400 years somewhere in there and
there's been a few developments in that
time the use of the black lives movement
back lives matter movement also differ
by race seventy six percent of black
voters well the positive you use are
evenly divided among white voters 42%
hold a positive view 39% a negative one
again one of the issues here is that
when it comes to these issues there is
so much semantic overload and when
people say black lives matter do they
mean that we want black people to live
full and prosperous lives if so there
should be 100% agreement I agree with
that if we with what we mean is the
black lives matter organization is good
no the black lives matter organization
is horrible neo-marxist garbage the
black lives matter organization again
not the protesters not the not the
phrase the actual organization black
lives matter which you can find on the
web at that means black lives matter dot
org or something it's a neo-marxist
garbage organization it is openly
anti-semitic it is it is it is a
terrible organization so the problem
with poll questions like this is it's
unclear what exactly people are asked to
side behind so you can unclear result
three-quarters of voters said they were
encouraged the country's addressing
long-standing issues of racism in
society so I
think this is this is the hopeful stat
here right that suggests that maybe that
this integrationists are not gonna win
is that it really suggests this stat
might be the most telling one of all
that 3/4 of voters say they're
encouraged the country is addressing
these issues meaning just by us
responding to this poll or hoping that
we can tie the country back together
again we've shown we don't like racism
so can we please go back to normal I
think that's really what that poll stat
is saying at the same time half said
they were concerned at the protests of a
racial issues are creating social unrest
and bringing too much change to the
country including embracing America's
history and significant figures in it
which of course that should again be a
75 percent proposition not a 50 percent
proposition with these stats show is
that we're living on nice edge when it
comes to the preservation of the factors
that allow a society continue forward in
positive fashion that's what my new book
is about it is being lived out every
single day I didn't know that my book
was gonna be quite as relevant as it has
become even in the past few weeks
speaking of which my new book how to
destroy America in three easy steps it
goes on sale today at 6 p.m. Eastern 3
p.m. Pacific we will be doing a virtual
live signing event later today with your
purchase of a signed copy you can write
in a question which may be read and
answered as I sign your book live on air
you can pre-order your signed copy and
write in your question at daily wire.com
slash Ben I've been talking extensively
about what the book is about I think I
don't need to pitch again the topic
because it speaks for itself so go check
it out right now at daily wire.com slash
then also well you're at it right you
just go get a reader's pass there's a
lot going on here at the website at
daily wire.com a reader's pass will cost
you normally about 3 bucks a month right
now you get it for under a dollar also
get excited because there is a daily
wire backstage this Friday so much
programming just for you plan your
schedules accordingly so you can join us
live for the premiere of Henson
hard-hitting around a table conservative
commentary so lots happening here at
Saylor where to go subscribe right now
you're listening to the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
hey so all of this plays out in real
life as violence takes place in the
streets it is very obvious to see how
the disintegration is really damaged the
country when you when you see what is
happening in Portland right now so in
Portland
you basically have rolling rice they've
been occurring for nigh on two months at
this point and the local authorities
have basically said that because the
system a system of which they are part
by the way because the system is
endemically racist and cruel and brutal
they're gonna stand aside and just let
this stuff happen so according to CNN
it's classic entrenchment with no end in
sight neither side is backing down as
protesters and federal agents continue
to periodically clash in downtown
Portland following an infusion of
federal resources in the area and the
Trump administration persists in seeking
political gain from ongoing tensions
gotta love CNN's coverage very objective
journalism in happening right there the
Trump administration persists in seeking
political gain from ongoing tensions how
about Portland has completely refused to
enact any semblance of law and order for
years at this point and the federal
government is saying No Mas we are done
here
no more according to Erin a Portland
resident who withheld his full name we
want to get them the eff out of our city
according to Acting DHS Secretary Chad
wolf he said I offer DHS supports help
locally address the situation going on
in Portland their only response was
please pack up and go home that's not
going to happen on my watch what
constitutes the situation Wolfe
described is not one mutually accepted
by those on different sides of the issue
the Trump administration says they are
fighting anarchists but protesters here
on the ground in Portland tell CNN the
president and his team are broad
brushing an entire movement
overwhelmingly peaceful despite some
periods of violence for purely political
reasons I love that when you shut down
rioting and looting that's political
when you ride and loot that's not
political also overwhelmingly peaceful
and the this phrase is being stretched
beyond all boundaries of linguistic
accuracy overwhelmingly peaceful does
not include you attacking a federal
courthouse overwhelmingly peaceful and
honestly I can't wait for the phrase
mostly peaceful to start being applied
in America's criminal courtrooms I'm
really looking forward to it it
shouldn't use it at the OJ trial you
know that night O'Shea was mostly
peaceful now really like for most of the
night like there were 12 hours of the
night between sunset and sunrise that
was like a 12 hour period and for at
least 10 hours and 45 minutes
Oh J was peaceful overwhelmingly
peaceful that
this kind of what absolute Mushmouth
garbage from the media it really is
incredible okay so president Trump is
now threatening a crackdown on violent
anarchists as you should because it
turns out that when a city refuses to
protect its law-abiding citizenry they
fail in their duty to protect the life
liberty and property of their citizenry
here was president Trump yesterday
correctly stating that he was not going
to allow law and order to completely
collapse in a major American city I'm
gonna do something that I can tell you
because we're not getting at New York
and Chicago and Philadelphia Detroit and
Baltimore and all of these Oakland is a
mess we're not gonna let this happen in
our country all run by Liberal Democrats
horsemen to some of these cities more
federal law enforcement that I can tell
you in Portland they've done a fantastic
job they've been there three days and
they've really have done a fantastic job
in a very short period of time no
problem they grab them a lot of people
in jail their leaders these are
anarchists these are not protesters okay
and he is correct about this the media
naturally conflate the anarchists and
the protesters it's amazing that rioters
in Portland overwhelmed police and
torched the police union headquarters
over the last couple of days but
apparently this is all just like normal
protesting according to the media and
you can tell which side the media are on
right so long as they're opposing from
they don't care if they are forwarding
the goals of so many members of an Tifa
they they don't care if they are helping
the anarchists in fact they kind of like
it because the system deserves to fall
the system deserves to go down the media
coverage of this stuff is absolutely
astonishing I mean truly truly crazy my
favorite piece on this was by Richard
Reid at the LA Times this is amazing so
in Portland there's a naked crazy lady
who showed up and started doing yoga
poses in front of the cops Richard Reid
apparently took out the Vaseline and had
himself an old time while writing this
piece she emerged as an apparition from
clouds of tear gas as federal agents
fired pepper balls and angry protesters
in the early Saturday darkness a woman
wearing nothing but a black face mask in
a stocking cap strode toward a dozen
heavily armed agents attired in
camouflage fatigues lined up across a
downtown Portland Street the agents
dispatched by the Trump administration
over vociferous objections of state and
city officials are part of a force that
has fired projectiles at and detained
activists
protesting nightly since the killing of
George Floyd numerous photos and videos
posted on Twitter showed the
unidentified woman as she halted in the
middle of the street at about 1:45 a.m.
she stood calmly a surreal image of
human vulnerability in the face of an
overwhelming force that has been
criticized nationally by civil rights
advocates the agents in gas masks and
helmets continued firing pepper balls in
a staccato pop-pop-pop heard on video
aiming low at the asphalt or puffs of
smoke mingled with clouds of gas at 1
watt at one point a fellow protester
clothes carried a homemade shield
started in front of a woman angling to
protect her but the woman's side stepped
him he jumped out of the way perhaps
realizing he made them both a target
before it was over she struck ballet
poses and reclined on the street she
also sat on the asphalt in a yoga like
position facing officers before they
left the woman making her statement
Saturday was altogether uninhibited at
one point standing on one leg raising
her arms in an archetype motion as she
struck ballet poses a patrol car arrived
and it doesn't officers in blue uniforms
were placed the line of agents whom
officials described as having been
targeted by protesters throwing rocks
bottles and pieces of metal oh well
that's kind of why they're not the naked
lady she stat and she sat in the street
facing them legs spread in the
headlights glare calm down there dude
calm down Richard Reid of the LA Times
later she rolled on her back in a
graceful pose then stood again images of
her on social media hearts back to a
previous iconic but clothed images
juxtaposing force and vulnerability
nudity has served as a form of protest
since at least the 11th century when
legend holds that Lady Godiva rode naked
failed only by her long hair on a horse
through Coventry England to protest
oppressive taxation on Twitter
sympathetic commentators will Kate's
quick to conclude that naked Athena as
they dubbed the Portland protester
caused the officer to turn tail others
on Twitter said the performance by a
white woman distracted from protests of
and justices faced by black people which
is hilarious ok I do love that the whoa
car even like this naked lady needs to
go because she's white get out get her
out of here she's protesting for us no
more naked lady but the media the
media's willingness to just just
basically bow at the altar of insanity
just because they are in favor of the
cast they like the cast the cast is good
according to many members of the media
it's ugly and has an underlying agenda
because guess what bad craps have
in the country right now NYPD
commissioner said yesterday that he was
losing counts of how many cops have been
attacked in New York which is correct
cops all over the United States are
being attacked violent crime rates are
going up
he knows paying the most it ain't cops
it is black citizens of state of places
like Chicago and New York where violence
has been skyrocketing there was the NYPD
Commissioner attack on police officers
I'm losing count to the officers that
I'm calling at home agent having surgery
this is just in the last week so this
all has prompted representative james
Clyburn of south carolina to compare
federal law enforcement to the gestapo
seriously a thing okay so a federal law
enforcement comes in because these
cities are refusing to enforce law and
he is now calling federal law
enforcement the Gestapo this is that
this is the new thing by the way there's
an entire column by the idiot Michelle
Goldberg at the New York Times
suggesting quote Trump's occupation of
American cities has begun you know as
opposed to the occupation by unlawful
forces that have completely shut down
major American cities for weeks on end
sending in the federal law enforcement
to arrest people
that's an occupation she says can we
call it fascism yet my favorite part is
that she literally does not understand
the law so she's like people are being
arrested without warrants okay you know
what that is called very often that is
just called an arrest felony arrests in
public places do not require a warrant
according to supreme court law they do
not felony arrest in place is not open
to the public require a warrant but if
you're walking around the park and
you're committing a felony or their
suspicion you're committing a felony you
can be arrested they don't need a
warrant to arrest you on sight yeah but
apparently this is very bad anyway
here's Jim's Clyburn suggesting that
Americans American soldiers right
federal law enforcement members of the
DHS are the Gestapo hey I find this
rather insulting to people who actually
survived the Gestapo here is james
Clyburn for all of a sudden these people
go in there nothing from the governor
nothing from local law enforcement just
show up with their faces covered in
unmarked cars that is the beginning of
the ending of this democracy that kind
of activity is an activity of a police
state and this president and this is
charged on
seems to be doing everything they
possibly can to impose Gestapo
activities in local communities Jim
Clyburn should know better than anybody
alive what actual Gestapo tactics look
like there's a man old enough to have
lived through Jim Crow and experience it
that was Gestapo stuff when the police
were actively an arm of segregation that
was gestapo stuff not when the police
are acting when the federal law
enforcement are acting to stop it from
burning federal buildings but the goal
of course is to conflate all of this is
to conflate all of this if you stand up
against the burning of federal buildings
if you stand up against the lawlessness
running rampant through America cities
you're just defending the system and if
people have to pay and innocent people
have to pay because the system collapses
that them as the brakes them's the
brakes
disintegration ISM does not care about
the costs it doesn't care about the
costs which is why of course the media
will go after it'll be very very upset
about the the vandalism committed by an
anti black lives matter protestors of a
black woman who went to the the giant
painting mural black lives matter in
front of Fifth Avenue a couple days ago
and she started pouring black paint on
there and shouting that black lives do
matter which is why we need to refund
the police but that's vandalism right
that's something that's worth
prosecuting obviously yeah throwing
paints on George Washington we leave
that alone and Fortas integrationist
this lady is obviously doing something
deeply wrong by defacing the the holy
yellow painting outside of the Fifth
Avenue Trump Tower even though it has
done nothing to say black lives that
mural has done nothing zero things as
the lady correctly notes again vandalism
not a great thing her generalized point
is correct the virtue signaling the
disintegration ISM has costs it does
have costs especially when you're
talking about removing police meanwhile
a democratic prosecutor is now charging
a Missouri couple for defending their
private property a Democratic prosecutor
who is up for reelection her name is Kim
Gardner announced on Monday she's
charging a st. Louis couple who defended
their private property using firearms
last month and they're ripped up and
down on social media I was so terrible
what happened they lived a private gated
community
protesters who become rioters the moment
you break the law they ripped doors off
the hinges of the private gated
community because they wanted to yell at
the mayor and they walked through and
apparently were threatening this guy and
his wife in the property the guy and his
wife walked out carrying guns now they
are being charged with fourth degree
misdemeanor assault as well as felony
unlawful use of weapon a corner the st.
Louis post-dispatch mark and Patricia
McCloskey each are now facing a single
felony counts of unlawful use of a
weapon exhibiting charging documents say
that Mark pointed an ar-15 rifle at
protesters and she wielded a
semi-automatic handgun placing those
protesters in fear of injury there's
only one problem there is a castle
doctrine in Missouri okay there's a
castle doctrine in Missouri and that
castle doctrine in Missouri means you
get to defend your private property mark
McCluskey appeared on Tucker Carlson's
show last night here's what he had to
say for himself the people that broke
into my neighborhood they're all
trespassing the the the guy that
recruited it that planned this event
said the next day that he intended to
break the law that it was his he needed
to break laws in order to send his
message none of those people are
arrested none of those people are
charged the prosecutor that the circuit
attorney has apparently decided that her
job as a prosecutor isn't to keep us
safe from criminals but to keep the
criminals safe from us it's it's a
bizarre-o upside-down world I've been a
little irritated by this process until
today
now I'm just flat out pissed off I mean
this is this has gotten to be outrageous
McClosky pointed out and one person
pulled out loaded pistol magazines click
them together and said you're next he
said we were threatened with our lives
threatened with the house being burned
down my office building being burned
down our dog's life being threatened it
was about as bad as it can get I really
thought it was the storming of the
Bastille we'd be dead the house would be
burned there was nothing we could do
about it
it was a large frightening crowd they
broke in the gate and they were coming
at us well the good news is that the
matura in Missouri Agee has filed to
dismiss the charges he says I won't
stand by while Missouri law is being
ignored so at least at least there is
that but the lawlessness the attempt to
tear down the system from within that is
the grave threats that are public we
should all all be able to stand with the
idea that well being law-abiding matters
that the system is built around freedom
it is not built around oppression
because if we believe the opposite then
the system will indeed collapse and what
replaces it is gonna be something not
quite as nice as the most powerful free
and prosperous nation in the history of
the world okay well we will be back here
later today with a couple of additional
hours of content otherwise we will see
you here tomorrow in the meantime go
pick up a copy of my book how to destroy
America in three easy steps and go over
to Daley wire.com slash men pick up
signed copy and watch our livestream
today when to a live book signing maybe
you will have your questions answered
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the bench Bureau
show the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling assistant
director pavel white house key technical
producer austin stevens playback and
media operated by Nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam
Tsai events audio is mixed by Mike
foramina hair and makeup is by Nika
Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen